this video is brought to you by keeps
[Music]
what's up guys michael here to talk
about one of my favorite directors a
visionary who has tackled topics as fun
as unhinged anchorman i have nothing
left nothing i've been reduced to rubble
and as fraught as wall street greed wait
wait he wanted to short housing bonds
who bets against housing
the man who once faked his own death for
a sketch comedy show adam mckay but
perhaps to your surprise i'm not exactly
here to extol the virtues of his latest
movie don't look up after hitting
netflix at christmas don't look up
quickly became one of the platform's
most watched films ever but as anyone
who's ever been the least popular kid at
the laser tag birthday party can tell
you popular doesn't always equal cool as
we see it don't look up far from
perpetuating mckay's legacy as one of
our era's foremost satirist doesn't
really hold up to scrutiny indeed we'd
argue that it fails to accomplish some
of the most basic and important tasks of
satire and before you throw a planet
destroying comet at my face hear us out
in this wisecrack edition on don't look
up satire or
propaganda spoilers ahead for of course
don't look up but also for sorry to
bother you a futurama episode and some
18th century satire about eating irish
babies but before we dive in i want to
talk to you about this video sponsor
keeps you may have heard the statistic
that two out of three men will
experience male pattern baldness of some
kind by the time they're 35.
that's wild but luckily keeps exists
it keeps is a subscription service that
makes it easier and more affordable to
prevent hair loss the process starts
with a free consultation with a licensed
keeps doctor your doc can help you get
the right combination of fda approved
prescriptions and over-the-counter
medications to help prevent further hair
loss and it's all shipped right to your
door
and you won't have to worry about
running out and ruining your treatment
routine because keeps automatically
refills your subscription every three
months you can message your keeps doctor
24 7 to update them on your progress or
ask them questions and keeps has more 5
star reviews than any of its competitors
get started today and you can see
results in 4 to 6 months
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
wisecrack or click the link in the
description to receive fifty percent off
your first order that's k e e p s dot
com slash wisecrack
now back to the show and now for a quick
recap don't look up chronicles the
attempts and ultimate failure of two
scientists to warn the world about a
planet-crushing comet that's rapidly
approaching earth they encounter a
dizzying array of incompetence there's
lots of shrugging equivocating and all
welling from politicians and media
figures alike in no small part because
our friends hail from a state school
let's get some other people on this some
ivy leaguers and you and i will review
the nasa plans okay after finally
convincing the president to nuke the
[ __ ] out of the comet the scientists get
hit with another rough blow see an elon
musk stand-in has discovered that the
comet might contain super valuable
minerals this
comet hurtling towards us from deep
space actually contains
at least 32 trillion dollars of these
critical materials so instead of blowing
up the comet he and the president decide
to blow it into lots of small pieces and
mine the crap out of it of course this
hair brain scheme fails and the planet
blows up world over everyone is dead a
married effing christmas so what gives
us plebes the right to declare don't
look up an unsuccessful satire let's get
into it now satire is a very old art
form dating back to either the ancient
greeks or ancient romans depending on
which antiquity nerd you ask the genre
is notoriously difficult to define
leaving most scholars to broadly label
it as the section of the venn diagram
where good fun meets sharp criticism in
the words of scholar p michael brown
satire aims to entertain and amuse as
well as to inform and reform like your
pleasant dinner date with a charismatic
anarchist satire should both show you a
good time and leave you reflecting on
the overall state of organized society
typically satire critiques prevailing
power structures whether political
social or economic this is why literary
theorist northrop frye referred to
satire as militant irony as ironic humor
is used to change minds the primary way
that satire achieves this according to
scholar daniel abrahams by employing a
misrepresentation that is the author
needs to identify a real problem come up
with a way to portray that problem in a
grotesque fabulous or over-the-top
fashion and then use that metaphorical
portrayal to critique and offer insight
into the real-life problem you know like
in jonathan swift's modest proposal
which argued that the solution to the
poverty of irish peasants was for them
to sell their babies to the rich as a
culinary delicacy
at first glance don't look up seems to
check this box you do understand that
this is an apocalyptic event this is
this is a large celestial body heading
towards our planet
at speeds not even indeed
i hear you
i hear you the planet destroying comet
is very blatantly a metaphor for the
planet destroying climate change
currently rearing its ugly head from
here to santa's workshop however as
abraham's notes a work is not satire
when there is no implicit criticism in
the misrepresentation and that's where
we really get stuck on don't look up see
climate change is inarguably caused by
man-made pollution a comet ricocheting
towards earth on the other hand is a big
cosmic oops in which mankind is
blameless this makes the metaphor pretty
shaky to begin with it might work if
humankind didn't cause climate change
but as just about every scientist with a
functional brain can tell you we totally
did by making mankind not complicit in
its own destruction don't look up misses
a big point about the climate crisis
what's more the solution to the planet
destroying comet doesn't work as a
metaphor either all they have to do is
shoot a nuke into the sky to stop the
disaster in contrast stopping climate
change would require a drastic
transformation in our lifestyle
particularly for folks in the high
polluting countries that's not to
mention that it would necessitate
creating entirely new economies and
systems of production and consumption in
the film the eventual decision not to
blow up the comment comes solely because
of a few people's greed in real life the
central reason for the tepid response to
climate change comes from a broad lack
of political will and a general
reluctance on behalf of all of us to
change our lifestyles let's be real
eating hamburgers while driving an suv
is an american pastime i will not
sacrifice and if leonardo dicaprio wants
to stop me then i invite him to come by
on his private jet and try if a comet
doesn't take him out first compare the
misrepresentation and don't look up to
say sorry to bother you in that film the
misrepresentation is in the
billionaire's plan to turn workers into
horses so that they can be stronger and
more efficient this functions exactly
the way abrahams says a
misrepresentation should it's a
grotesque exaggeration of a very real
phenomenon in which capitalism
dehumanizes workers reducing them
entirely to their capacity to get it
done so ceos can make a few more bucks
the causality in this misrepresentation
unlike don't look up is pretty spot on
the failure and misrepresentation pretty
much dooms don't look up to be rather
toothless as a satire but there are
other problems that we can understand by
comparing it to more successful satires
take the film's representation of the
president with no disrespect meant to
national treasure meryl streep her
character is pretty one-dimensional
cravenly obsessed with maintaining power
over say protecting the planet from
total destruction the president reads as
a blatant caricature of a republican
politician with no redeeming qualities
denouncing her for the film's presumably
mostly liberal audience is a no-brainer
it doesn't actually require any complex
thought or questioning of prevailing
power structures the message seems to be
bad politician equals bad sorry to
bother you on the other hand might lead
a viewer to reflect on their own
complicity and hustle culture and
exploitative work environments but don't
look up makes it easy to sit back and be
proud of yourself for only voting for
the good politicians if those even exist
spoiler alert that there are no good
politicians plato himself said so in the
republic so
who are we to argue in understanding
don't look up's failures it's important
to note that satire's success is largely
contingent on its context in part who
the presumed audience is going to be the
message of don't look up is pretty
clearly designed to appeal to a liberal
audience who is aware of and already
deeply concerned about climate change
and who have their parents netflix
password my mom's password by the way is
golfmom64 in this way painting the end
of the world as the fault of republican
politicians conservative reporters and a
climate-denying portion of the public
isn't provoking novel thoughts or inward
reflection in its audience it's
reinforcing what they already believe
according to scholar connell condren
this is symptomatic of plenty of modern
satire he writes that maybe that is so
much satire has become mainstream mass
entertainment that the moral edge is
blunted or is being concentrated on
acceptably safe targets and so treads
carefully around contemporary patterns
of taboo and sensitivity
particularly given the film's assumed
audience critiquing a republican
president or a universally derided media
world is explicitly pretty safe rather
than provocative or complex the message
almost seems to be that if a good
democratic president was in charge maybe
the world wouldn't have ended so hey
vote blue
the opposite of this of course is the
classic scene in get out where bradley
whitford's character non-coincidentally
an actor from liberal favorite the west
wing says by the way i i would have
voted for obama for a third term if i
could best president my lifetime
handstand compare don't look up to a
satirical show like veep which depicts a
strong female democratic president who
is utterly selfish and power hungry
selena myers pursues a green jobs
initiative not because she cares about
the environment but because she wants
people to think she does am i still
getting unequivocal support on clean
jobs
far from portraying the good democratic
leader in the mythological vein of say
an fdr veep suggests to its presumably
liberal audience that power hungriness
is symptomatic of all politicians it's
like opposite day west wing a show that
basically argues that good politicians
will save us all this is far more
provocative dispelling any notions that
democrats are the good guys who will
simply solve all of our problems at the
same time selena myers is far from a
caricature like the president and don't
look up she is deeply human and at times
even sympathetic in her frustrations and
insecurities this ultimately makes for a
far more interesting critique of
politicians and of course it can force
the audience to reckon with our own
tendency to turn our favorite
millionaire political candidates into
humanitarian heroes it's worth noting
that satire can be said to have an
explicitly philosophical function if
philosophy begins in wonder and
encourages us to live an examined life
satire via its use of militant irony is
trying to do something similar as
kierkegaard wrote satire causes pain but
this pain is oriented towards healing
when i watch get out i find myself
horrified that the good white liberals
are literally colonizing the bodies of
black people this forces me to think
about racism and my own privilege and
power in a more critical way which could
be painful but this pain leads to
healing when i then see the world in a
different light but let's get back to a
movie that dares to ask what if we acted
like leonardo dicaprio wasn't
objectively hot perhaps the most ironic
part of the don't look up discourse is
the oddly moralizing contention that if
you don't appreciate the film you don't
care about climate change most notably
this was argued by none other than mr
mckay who really could have just logged
off of twitter and stared at his oscar
statue instead this argument as people
who are capital c concerned about
climate change strikes us as
scientifically speaking
totally bananas it's like saying that if
you don't think the 1995 film water
world is a masterpiece then you're just
not concerned about melting ice caps and
drinking pee to understand why let's go
back to abraham's as he notes when
considering an audience's reaction to a
satire an important distinction for
understanding humor and satirical
misrepresentation is that between
prescribed and merited responses the
prescribed response to a work of art is
the response that the work attempts to
bring about in its audience the merited
response is the response that the
audience ought to have that is to say
all satire attempts to entertain and
critique and to provoke thought about
the world around us this is the
prescribed response that satire wants to
achieve but not all satire actually
earns the merited response when we
critique don't look up we're certainly
not arguing with its prescribed response
to galvanize action to combat climate
change that's a totally important and
valid goal but the merited response that
is to say the response it actually earns
isn't really successful when mckay
suggests that not liking the film means
you don't care about climate change he's
conflating prescribed and merited
responses to put it more simply you can
care about climate change and still
think the film fails as satire so what
does successful climate change satire
look like we'd point to the futurama
episode in which it's discovered that a
huge ball of garbage shot into space by
21st century humans is headed for earth
this right here is incisively militant
irony about the sort of short-term
compromising solutions that are all too
familiar in global climate policy adding
to the irony protagonist fry's 20th
century messiness ultimately saves the
day he teaches the people of a new new
york how to make trash and they create a
new garbage ball that will redirect the
other one into the sun of course the new
garbage ball might come back in hundreds
of years but who cares about that should
we really be celebrating i mean what if
the second garbage ball returns to earth
like the first one did
who cares that won't be for hundreds of
years this is just
better satire than don't look up first
off it's simply funnier
we're gonna die right right
but more importantly it's much more
confrontational it immediately makes the
problem our fault the inevitable result
of choices made by corporations and
individuals while don't look up is
willing to say that our society is
poorly positioned to respond to a crisis
like this it doesn't clarify that the
system we live in and the world we built
is at fault for the crisis and that's
what's key here global warming isn't
just the result of a few billionaires
and companies acting recklessly it's the
fault of a system that demands infinite
growth and consumption don't look up
never engages with the systematic issue
itself only with its symptoms and so
we're never asked to look at the world
around us critically only to clap along
as the movie turns up the heat on its
deserving targets in this way we see
don't look up less as satire and more as
a piece of propaganda albeit propaganda
with a message we can get behind when
we're all one hundred percent for sure
gonna die
as scholar nicholas call writes an
effective propagandist does not teach
his or her audience something new but
rather tells them something they have
always thought
this sounds a lot like what mckay is
doing reinforcing his audience's
pre-existing beliefs and hopes of
spurring them to action anyway we'd
argue that don't look up is pretty
successful propaganda it does call
attention to a genuinely terrifying
existential crisis for humanity even if
it's just validating the pre-existing
beliefs of its audience and that's a
fine goal even if it's a lot less
interesting than that of a good piece of
satire but what do you guys think have
we convinced you that don't look up is
more propaganda than satire or are you
at least thankful that we tried let us
know what you think in the comments big
thanks to our patrons for all your
support and don't forget to check out
our podcast hit that subscribe button
like you're throwing fingerling potatoes
into your shopping cart and don't forget
to ring that bell and as always thanks
for watching later
[Music]
you